[Music]  i'm just a simple citizen concerned like  many about the future of our planet  discovering sailing and what's happening  to the world i wanted to take action  we're here to show people the impacts of  climate change  by the stories of the people the  scientists and the locals that see these  design packs  first hand with our vessel north about  we also participate in various research  programs to better anticipate and  understand  climate change we hope to convince  people  here in europe that climate change is  not in 50 or 100 years  is happening now  greenland is so important to the changes  affecting our climate  [Music]  [Applause]  climate change isn't this far-fetched  idea  people here are seeing first-hand the  changes already affecting our world  the one important thing about climate  change it's got to be  hope society is changing it doesn't  happen overnight but  it's already changing at an incredible  pace and let's  change the world together